[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like buttons the only way the
YouTube algorithm notices
me
the universe is incomprehensibly vast
Earth is an unprotected bubble
surrounded in infinite Cosmic
emptiness within that darkness that
Eternal Blackness who knows what might
wait and what might eventually call out
to us the LIE behind the star follows
the one aishi a civilization who deep
within caverns of the earth discovered
strange pulsating
mushrooms mushrooms which they grew to
understand were actually reacting to
something remote something very remote
the bioluminescent mushrooms Were
Somehow responding to a distant signal
from outer space a signal undetectable
through normal means the consumption of
the mushroom brought visions of the
cosmos a wealth of outside knowledge at
night under the influence of the
mushrooms they would dance wildly
beneath the Earth illuminated by the
thousands upon thousands of pulsating
fungi filled with the music of the
universe as time went on the attachment
between the on alichi and the mushrooms
grew stronger some among them claimed
that they could themselves hear the call
of the signal which they named the
kamora in time three children were born
the W Ali using what they had learned
changed the children somehow made them a
part of the fungal Network they became
the three who are one by directly
linking into the fungal Network they
could manipulate it initiate its growth
use it to produce chemicals and
biological substances of all kinds the
three who are one were granted by the
fungus near unending life around them
eventually grew an immense City all
formed from the biological matter of the
fungus it was said that the three who
are one could hear the kamora at all
times that their purpose was Guided by
the kamora and the kamora
alone the ones El she prospered and grew
advancing themselves technologically
philosophically and intellectually
whilst simultaneously the kamora took on
heavily mystical and religious
significance many believed that the
kamora was the voice of a goddess that
the W aishi were her chosen people to
the W Ali the aeki The Outsiders played
no role they were not chosen by
Kimora eventually it became the mission
of the One Alicia to find their goddess
the three who are one declared that
those who heard the kamur most strongly
would be taken as children and trained
for a mission a mission they may never
return from aboard a biological vessel
they would leave the Earth and seek her
out but there were many things about
this so-called Kimora that they did not
understand the three who are one when
they chose to speak spoke rarely to
clarify the kamora's will among the ones
zishi several tribes had developed each
with their own way of interpreting
kamora's will some believed that the
pursuit of the kamora should be
discriminated on on the basis of
devoutness others thought that only the
most intelligent should be allowed to go
the tribes each had one thing in common
however they would all be willing to
send some of their children for the
opportunity from each tribe a few
children blessed to hear the kamora's
voice were sent into the Heart of the
City to be trained nine were ultimately
Chosen and nine would eventually leave
entering the unknown Abyss to seek out
kamora but there were secrets in that
Abyss in a universe so vast and dark
what could project a signal as powerful
as the kamora through time and space an
advanced civilization some other
powerful intelligence beyond our
understanding could The kamora Troop
truly be a goddess what actually Waits
at the origin Point what will the nine
encounter if you've never read the LIE
behind the star that's okay because only
myself and a few other people have
that's because the LIE behind the star
is my book and it's launching on
Indiegogo today the LIE behind the star
volume 1 is my first ever science
fiction graphic novel as some of you may
know a couple years ago I released a
fantasy story called tadia my first
graphic novel and now I and my creative
team are back at it with the LIE behind
the star I've been bringing great
science fiction books to you guys'
attention for years now and that's
because I really love the books that I
talk about science fiction in my opinion
is the most powerful genre out there
because it tells us about our future and
what we could be and what not to be
science fiction can be full of mystery
and horror and wonder it's about the
universe and its Secrets we've been
working on the LIE behind the star for a
few years now getting concept art done
working out the narrative and we're
finally ready to launch I like
philosophical science fiction I'm a big
fan of Dune obviously for its
exploration of religion and fanaticism
when it's extended to a galactic scale I
wanted to do a story about a conflict
between religion and faith and science
and reason because that was part of my
own story coming from a very religious
Southern background there were so many
things that I had to unlearn and come to
terms with because at some point I begin
to realized that my perception of
reality wasn't necessarily how things
were I also read everything that Octavia
Butler wrote over the last several years
and there was something about the way
her work just kind of confronts you with
uncomfortable truths and the way she
uses that uncomfortability to disarm you
to make a point I just think that she
was really effective in her work at
doing that so I defin took inspiration
from that as far as the art in the book
we have the amazing Matthew Welden
returning from tadia doing all the
internal art as well as John franois
Belo of Image Comics Fame doing the
coloring for the book I could not be
more happy with the creative team for
the book The Art is absolutely gorgeous
in my opinion the LIE behind the star
campaign will run for the next 30 days
and if I've ever entertained you and if
you have the means consider pledging for
an ebook or if you are so inclined a
paperback or hard cover and yes there
will also be an audio reading of the
script performed by myself as well and
if we can hit certain stretch goals that
will actually be upgraded to an audio
drama with original music and original
sound effects thanks guys so much all
links are in the
[Music]
description The Silence of the vacuum an
empty expanse were not even sound can
exist punctuated only by The Faint hum
of cosmic radiation serves as a stark
backdrop to the Grand spectacle of the
universe the distant macroscopic
movement of the quazar a celestial
object so distant that its light takes
billions of years to reach us is a
testament to the cosmic scale of time
and space its luminous core emits energy
that outshines entire galaxy GES a
Celestial Lighthouse guiding us through
the vast Cosmic
ocean the violent cycling of atoms
hidden within the heart of stars is a
never-ending dance of creation and
destruction nuclear fusion and fision
processes Within These Celestial
furnaces produce the elements that make
up everything around us from the air we
breathe to the Earth beneath our feet
the crushing weight of the black hole
gravity a force so strong that not even
light can escape its grasp distorts
SpaceTime itself it forms a mysterious
and inexorable presence in the cosmos a
Riddle That beckons scientists and
philosophers to unlock its
Secrets a blue bubble surrounded in
Endless Darkness Earth is a fragile
Oasis in the vast Cosmic desert it
cradles the intricacies of Life a
delicate equilibrium sustained by
countless interconnected systems and
interdependencies a billion stars bear
witness to
Eternity their light traveling through
the universe bearing the stories of
galaxies and civilizations long past
each one a cosmic Beacon a reminder of
the unimaginable scale and age of the
cosmos our understanding of the universe
relies on observing
phenomenon yet the universe's full
extent eludes us for it Harbors sights
beyond our visual perception but what is
something called out to us from that
infinite dark Opening Our Eyes what then
would we
[Music]
see